as any fan will tell you marvel's many
blockbusters are packed full of truly
incredible moments but which ones are
the most electrifying of all from
devastating cliffhangers to epic fight
scenes these are the biggest
jaw-dropping moments in marvel movie
history everyone knew what they were in
for with avengers infinity war earth's
mightiest heroes would have a tough
fight against thanos and it was likely
that they wouldn't get away without
losing one or two members of the team
but even if they didn't win they'd at
least prolong the battle until the
sequel surely thanos wouldn't actually
win right and yet as infinity war came
to a shocking close thanos dream of
ending half of all life in the universe
was finally realized audiences around
the world watched in horror as everyone
from black panther to spider-man
dissolved into dust before their very
eyes it was a snap heard around the
universe one that continues to echo
through the mcu to this day this was
something no comic book movie had even
attempted before it was ambitious
terrifying and utterly unexpected
avengers end game was a film that had to
follow thanos's snap by both meditating
on the fallout of the tragedy and
finding a way to rise above it as a
result it's a story packed to the
rafters with great moments any one of
which could stake a claim as the movie's
best from captain marvel's late game
entrance to tony sacrifice to that
iconic portal sequence well they're all
great but there's great and then there's
this
from the moment that hammer hovers you
know exactly what's coming cap lifting
mjolnir is a concept first toyed with
all the way back in age of ultron and
everyone knew it was coming eventually
but it's still such a masterfully
executed payoff that you just can't help
but cheer and it doesn't exactly hurt
that the ensuing showdown with thanos is
one of the most satisfying scenes in the
whole mcu either it really doesn't get
much better than this
there were a whole heap of narrative
challenges to overcome in that first
avengers movie the film had to
successfully convey loki as a villain
big enough for all six heroes
convincingly set up tension between them
and then proved that they're a great
team after all and then amidst all that
the avengers had to pretty much redefine
the character of the hulk luckily marvel
rose to the occasion and then some
hulk's whole arc in the film from sad
sack scientist reluctant hero is
magnificent but his best moment comes
when banner finally arrives at the final
fight in new york surrounded by the
city's ruins he utters arguably his most
famous mcu line now might be a really
good time for you to get angry
that's my secret captain
[Music]
i'm always angry and then he lets loose
with a punch that shows the hulk for
what he really is raw power hulk's had
plenty of great moments since then but
not have been quite as potent as this
x2 x-men united is among the best of
fox's x-men films largely because it's a
movie that retains what everyone liked
about the first x film while upping the
ante in just about every respect it does
this not only by keeping the focus on
wolverine and rogue but also introducing
new characters with dazzling abilities
and raising the stakes on almost every
action set piece while magneto's prison
escape is a favorite scene for some fans
for others the undisputed champion of
this film happens in its opening moments
when nightcrawler breaks into the oval
office and attempts to assassinate the
president it's later revealed that
nightcrawler has been brainwashed and
that his plight is at the center of a
massive conspiracy to rid the world of
mutant kind he also turns out to be a
perfectly nice guy who'd never
deliberately do what he did in the
film's opening minutes but that doesn't
stop the sequence from packing a serious
punch and even today it remains one of
the most thrilling action scenes in the
world of comic book movies since its
release in 2004 spider-man 2 has been
followed by six other spider-man films
four of which starred other actors as
the iconic web slinger but for many fans
sam raimi's sequel remains a gold
standard for both spidey and superhero
movies largely thanks to its emotional
core and superb action sequences this is
best demonstrated in the still legendary
sequence in which spider-man has to stop
a runaway train after dr octopus
sabotages the controls though it would
later be topped in scope by homecoming's
ferry sequence raimi directs the heck
out of the train rescue in which peter
parker unmasked and desperate sticks his
webbing to various passing buildings in
an effort to make a sling with his own
body but what really elevates the scene
above all the rest is the moment in
which peter passes out from sheer
exhaustion and waits to find all the
train passengers staring at him they're
so grateful for his help and so
understanding of how important
spider-man is to their city that they
hand back his mask and promise to never
tell anyone who he is it's a beautiful
final touch to a truly spectacular scene
logan isn't a particularly complex film
by comic book movie standards it doesn't
introduce a horde of new heroes and it
doesn't end with a massive cgi heavy
apocalyptic showdown at its heart this
is a movie about a man who's waiting to
die and finds a reason to live a little
longer considering the heart of the
movie is the relationship between logan
and his young clone laura you'd be
forgiven for expecting some kind of
action team up between the two but this
doesn't occur until the very end of the
movie when it finally does happen
however it's obvious that this is going
to be more than just a fight scene when
laura realizes logan has her back it's a
tremendous emotional payoff and as
logan's body fills up with bullets it
becomes clear that this isn't going to
end like other superhero fights either
the whole sequence is a tremendous
combination of action and emotional
intensity making for a truly memorable
climax and setting up one of the
greatest endings in comic book movie
history thor ragnarok is a film that
sets out to reimagine both thor and the
world around him as a result it's a
movie full of fresh sights and sounds
that offer a lighter and yet more
emotionally resonant take on the god of
thunder there are a number of absolutely
dazzling moments in the film but they
don't get much better than that final
fight as hell as armies close in on his
friends an injured one-eyed thor is
desperate for some kind of help then he
thinks of his father's words realizes
his power comes from within and
unleashes a lightning bolt that finally
slows hella down scored by led
zeppelin's immigrant song thor makes the
mother of all entrances as he joins the
battle on the bifrost throw in valkyrie
and her fireworks strut loki's
redemption and hulk suplexian fenrir and
you've got the recipe for one of the
mcu's best fight scenes spider-man far
from home establishes that the mcu's
peter parker does indeed have a spider
sense which is ant has helpfully
nicknamed the peter tingle he also
apparently has the legendary parker luck
because just when you think the kid has
finally caught a break the film pulls
the rug out from under him by the end of
far from home everything seems to be
going well for peter he's in a
relationship with mj all of his friends
made it home from europe safe and he
cemented his place as tony stark's
successor in the mcu that all comes
crashing down however when it's revealed
by a jay jonah jameson that mysterio has
framed spider-man for his apparent death
and exposes his secret identity to the
world
the long-awaited reintroduction of j
jonah jameson to the mcu was enough to
put jaws on the floor but then the scene
went further by totally ruining peter
parker's life this one's going to take
some fixing a film like captain america
civil war is more or less purpose-built
for big surprise moments and introduced
both black panther and spider-man to the
mcu and pitted various heroes against
each other in a super vs super battle
like no other and that iconic airport
scene's biggest moment turned out to be
the biggest in a very literal sense this
is the moment in which scott lang
reveals that he's capable of growing his
body to a gigantic size seemingly out of
nowhere ant-man grows several dozen feet
and plucks war machine right out of the
air and while he would later reappear in
both ant-man and the wasp and avengers
end game this giant man moment will
always hold a special place in fans
hearts steve rogers isn't a superhero in
the same sense that say thor or the hulk
is nor is he an ordinary man in the same
way that tony stark is steve rogers
treatment with the super soldier serum
has enhanced his body to the point that
he's essentially reached maximum human
potential in terms of strength speed
endurance and more he's quite literally
the best version of a normal human being
without any external enhancements and
because he has a heart determination of
steve rogers he's able to push himself
to the point where even other enhanced
humans wouldn't be able to go
i can do this all day yeah i know
i know
this is perhaps best exemplified in
captain america's civil war when camp
single-handedly holds a helicopter in
place mid takeoff for several seconds
using nothing but a sheer strength and
his willpower even for cap it's quite a
feat and chris evans startling ability
to make his biceps pop is enough to make
this sequence even more memorable
captain marvel arrived in the mcu at a
time when thanos had already snapped
when the avengers had assembled three
times and when characters such as vision
and giant man were practically
commonplace despite all of this captain
marvel had to convince fans that they
were witnessing the creation of the
mcu's most powerful hero someone
stronger than virtually any other
avenger in the room so how did the movie
do this simple by having the hero defeat
a whole army all by herself after
choosing to defend the persecuted
scrolls a fully powered carol danvers
takes out an entire cree squadron and
then flies to a massive creek warship
destroying it in seconds and sending the
surviving bad guys packing and from that
point on there's absolutely no doubt
that carol danvers is a force to be
reckoned with
no one knew quite what to expect from
venom the first solo film to star the
titular anti-hero would it be overly
dark and gritty so self-serious that it
became silly too focused on its creature
to add any real humanity it wasn't easy
to pin down from the marketing either
which is why the end result was so
refreshing a genuinely quirky blend of
darkness action and self-aware humor
venom begins as a sort of body horror
film as eddie brock accidentally comes
across the symbiote and then struggles
to understand why there's a voice in his
head all of a sudden it's an adjustment
period that manifests itself in all
kinds of ways but the most memorable one
occurs when eddie storms into a fancy
san francisco restaurant in an effort to
confront his former partner with his
discoveries of course the venom symbiote
has other plans and by the end of the
scene eddie has submerged himself in a
live lobster tank the whole scene just
gets weirder when eddie snatches up one
of the crustaceans and chows down on a
raw seafood lunch although venom
certainly has splashier moments along
the way this is the one that set the
tone for this particular superhero
franchise funny unpredictable and more
than a little bizarre
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you